- [Kanniah] My co-speaker
Frenil could not be here
for personal reasons.
Hence, today I'm privileged
to be a solo speaker.
Welcome to our session ISV404,
Build Resilient SaaS:
Multi-Account Resilient Testing Patterns.
I'm delighted you decided to join
and appreciate you investing
your valuable time with us.
How many of you have experienced
that panic in using 3M call
about your multi-tenant
SaaS enrollment failures?
Any volunteers? 1, 2, 3. Great.
What if you could
proactively validate your
multi-account resilient architecture
against controlled experiments
in terms of injecting
faults to ensure that,
you know, you have your workloads
tested within the tenant boundaries
as well as mitigating any other failures?
Today we'll explore how
the leading ISVs use
AWS Fault Injection Service to ensure that
the SaaS architectural designs
are validated and tested
without impacting your SaaS
architectural critical components.
And usually these failures are injected
to ensure that you mitigate
any of your end customer
availability issues in
terms of services or SLAs
that you committed to your end customers.
I'm Kanniah VJ, a senior
solution architect
aligned with UK ISVSA team.
I'm with AWS over five years.
I'm based out of Dublin.
So today, first we'll
begin with understanding
some of the core principles
of SaaS architectures
and how every successful
SaaS solutions underpins
how a multi-tenant solution
has to be operated.
And then we will really understand
how SaaS providers must adopt
a comprehensive resilience framework.
Again, we talk about
some of the fundamentals
of how AWS shares our
experience in truly building
resilient applications to our customers.
And then we will talk about
real world user journey
with an AWS reference architecture
of a multi-tenant control plane
and an application plane architectures,
where we have set up two
of the SaaS solutions
to showcase resilience testing patterns.
Again, core of today's
talk is to showcase you
multiple resilience testing patterns
on how do you induce various faults
following the AWS best practices
and some of the SaaS fundamentals.
And then finally, you'll
walk away with key learnings
on how to adopt multi-account
resilience experiments
for your own SaaS architectures
and irrespective of your
current maturity level.
And finally, I'll open up the floor
for any question and answer sessions.
So to build a truly
resilient SaaS architectures,
SaaS provider must adopt
six critical pillars.
Robust tenant isolation to
prevent security breaches
and data breaches.
Noisy neighbor mitigation
to maintain consistent user experience
as well as the overall performance
of your multi-tenant solution.
Comprehensive identity
and access management
to ensure that you have
secure tenant boundaries.
Tenant aware observability to ensure
that you can instrument
various tenant usage resources
and service throttling limits
and various other
observability related metrics
so that you can withstand
any sort of disruption
in terms of failures.
Strategic tiering to serve
your diversified customer segments.
And last but not the least,
the cost aware tracking
mechanism to ensure
that you will be able to charge
back to your end customers.
And all these fundamentals
remains the core building block
for you to build truly
resilient solution on AWS.
And one of the best practices
as part of AWS Well-Architectured
reliability pillar
is a failure management,
where we talk about test reliability.
And the idea of correlating
SaaS fundamentals
with the AWS Well-Architectured
reliability pillar
is to ensure that you need
to consider reliability
as core pillar to validate
and test your workloads
against any disruptions.
And this will ensure that your workload is
ready to withstand both
for partial failures
or the gray failures
against your functional
and non-functional requirements.
And again, the objective here
is to have a controlled
experiments which you'll use
as part of your multi-account
SaaS architectures
so that you would be able to
either completely avoid minimal impact
or completely no disruptions
without impacting your critical workloads.
And if you really want to deep dive,
feel free to grab the QR code.
Now how do you approach
a structured methodology
and a continuous iterative
process for you to build
and manage your SaaS architectures on AWS?
So this is where to
address this challenge,
AWS developed resilience
lifecycle framework
in sharing resilience learnings
and some of the best practices
that we have learned based
on working with hundreds
and thousands of customers to
truly build resilient systems.
Now in terms of resilience lifecycle,
we have five critical stages
where you can adopt
various best practices,
AWS services and strategies,
to mitigate your resiliency objectives.
To start with, you will
set the objectives,
and at this stage,
your key objective would
be to really understand
what level of resiliency is
needed for your workloads.
This goes back to purely
a business conversation,
not a technology conversation,
in aligning your objectives
in terms of RTO, RPO,
arrival ability, or any
SLAs that you have committed
as a business to your end customers.
With those objectives in mind,
you work towards the second
phase of design and implement.
So this is where you would
anticipate various failure modes
to ensure that your
workloads is rightly designed
with the right technical architecture
and accordingly adopt the right tools.
So once you design and implement
based on the objectives
that you have set in the previous stage,
you move towards the third
stage of evaluate and test.
And the primary focus would be
to perform resilience testing.
And here again, you
know, we are not trying
to bring in chaos here.
It's about inducing faults
with the controlled experiments
to ensure that you know the limits
or the boundaries to
reduce any blast radius.
And there are two phases
to evaluate and test
where the first stage would be
to do a pre-deployment activities
related to your software
development lifecycle
that you traditionally do,
and the post-deployment activities
where you focus on resilience assessments,
disaster recovery testing,
or even resilience testing using AWS
Fault Injection Service.
Depending on the nature of your
SaaS architectural workloads distributed,
either single account
or multiple AWS account.
And then once you're happy
with your test results,
you move on towards operate.
This is where you look at
your observability tools,
logs, metrics, and various
other best practices
to instrument various disruptions
causing your availability issues
or maybe various other
system dependency issues.
And once you have the
right instrumentation
in terms of observability,
you move on towards respond and learn,
where based on your various incidents
that your operational team manages
in terms of infrastructure
failure, availability,
or application level failures,
you would really have a
mitigation strategy on runbooks,
playbooks, and operating
procedures, and all other,
you know, incident management
related best practices.
And then you continually learn on
how you are mitigating those failures
and then you funnel those
learnings into your set objectives
and various other stages as
part of the overall flywheel.
And I think the key goal
here is that you can
apply these flywheel for
your existing workload
or even the new workload.
Feel free to grab the QR
code if you're interested.
We have a very great
detailed white paper on this.
Now this brings us to a next topic
of phase of resilience experiments.
So for every experiment that
you want to induce fault
for your specific workloads,
you eventually get
started with steady state.
Steady state is pretty much
what a normal looks like
for your workload behavior,
depending on your user traffic patterns
or depending on your, you know,
your service that you're
offering to your end customers.
So you need to measure
your steady state behavior
to know based on metrics or logs
that how your system is behaving.
So once you know the baseline
version of your steady state,
you move towards the hypothesis.
Hypothesis is nothing but a scenario
where you want to
validate your assumptions
or weaknesses of your workload,
which is more of unknown.
And how do you know these
unknown into a known factor is
defining the hypothesis with
the clear business outcomes
that what is the
weaknesses of your workload
and what you want to validate
with the specific objectives.
And once you define the hypothesis,
you proceed towards the third phase
of running an experiment.
So this is where, based on the hypothesis
that you have defined,
that say I want to induce fault A
to the component A, B, and C.
And then I'm expecting
that the system behavior
will be either a fault
error rate increasing 10%
or maybe an infrastructure failure
or any other failures that
you're planning to induce.
So, for example, if you have an EKS Pod,
then you want to induce
an EKS Pod CPU stress,
or maybe if you have an RDS database,
you want to fail over to another region,
depending on the hypothesis
that you want to define.
So once you run the experiments
using AWS Fault Injection
Service, a multi-account setup,
you would really evaluate now,
okay, now your system has behaved
and you want to go back and
verify what was the outcome
and what kind of metrics that you observed
to verify those systems.
And then accordingly you
move towards improvement
of your architecture or runbook
or playbook or any sort of,
you know, learnings that you
had as part of this hypothesis.
And this flywheel has to adopt
for every resilience
experiments that you define.
If you don't do this, then
eventually it becomes,
you know, a confusion for anyone involved
as part of this phases of
resilience experiments.
So be sure that you create this
and apply as part of the
resilience lifecycle,
which is more of an inner flywheel
within the resilience framework.
And now this brings to a situation where,
now this is all sounds great,
but how do I get started on AWS?
I have tens or hundreds of AWS accounts,
you know, where my SaaS
workloads are deployed,
how do I induce faults,
not in one single account
but multiple accounts?
So this is where AWS
Fault Injection Service
helps you to do that.
So the way it works is,
again, it's a fully managed service
for you to eliminate any heavy
lifting that you have to do
in terms of building custom
scripts or any other,
you know, implementation
that you have to perform
to automate or induce these faults.
So the way it works is where
FIS integrates with IAM,
where you have to define
an orchestrator role
as a single pane of glass
to induce various faults
with other accounts.
And then you can access FIS
through management console,
CLI, or APIs, or any means
that you want to integrate
or get started.
The very first step is to
configure an experiment template.
And this experiment template
has three critical components.
First is an action.
Action is nothing but the
activity that you want to perform
in terms of the faults,
depending on the nature of
your AWS service adoption.
And then once you define the action,
so it could be sequential action
or it could be parallel
action you want to take
as part of the faults.
And then you would go ahead
and define the targets.
In this case, the target
would be the AWS resources
nature of your architectural patterns,
whether you're using serverless
architectural pattern
or maybe traditional EC2
based deployment models.
You decide on those
specific targeted resources,
and accordingly, the
action will be induced
with those specific targeted resources.
And the third critical
element is FIS safeguard.
So again, as I mentioned earlier,
resilience testing is about
a controlled experiment
to reduce the blast radius.
So this is where you will use safeguards
to define a stop condition
for these experiments
to say that I have certain
thresholds set for my experiment.
When those thresholds are met,
the experiment can be
stopped by creating an alarm.
So that way you're not
kind of creating a chaos
with your upstream or downstream systems.
And then once you define
all these three components,
that's where it goes in
as an experiment template.
You can also use scenario libraries,
which we have prebuilt as an
AWS opinionated recommendation,
you know, which we think is
a common set of experiments
that customers are interested,
where you can get started much faster.
So once you configure
the experiment templates,
eventually you can start the experiment
or stop the experiment in an
(indistinct) basis as well.
And another great thing about
FIS is that it enables you to
have your third party
observability tools out of AWS
to consume or, you know,
consume certain events from those tools
via Amazon EventBridge,
where you can start the experiment
or the start the experiment.
It creates sort of an
openness platform for you
to have a single pane of glass
in terms of the FIS experiments
against your AWS resources.
And again, there's a great
case study from BMW Group
who have actually leveraged FIS
to identify their weaknesses
of some of their critical components
and they have actually
adopting this as a mental model
to evaluate various critical components.
So now we want to talk
about a real world scenario
of a SaaS workload architecture.
So let's take an example of
a persona who are interacting
with the SaaS architecture.
So for today's session we
have two critical personas
who are trying to interact
with the overall SaaS architecture.
So one is the SaaS provider
who are an software company
or an organization
trying to design, build,
and deploy and manage the SaaS offering
to their end customers.
And as you know, SaaS providers typically
have to manage multiple tenants.
It's a multi-tenant solution
we are talking about.
So as per AWS best practices,
we recommend as a SaaS provider
to break your overall
SaaS workload architecture
into control plane and
an application plane.
So as in terms of the
control plane operations,
these are what you see on the screen,
like tenant management, admin management,
billing metrics, and authentication,
are the core common modules
as a global services serving
across multiple tenants.
Now these SaaS providers eventually have
to operate their workload at scale
to ensure that tenants are happy
in terms of the service offering
and they are eventually paying
for what they're consuming.
And the second key persona is the tenant
who are actually the consumer
of the SaaS application
offered by the SaaS provider.
And for today's session,
I've set up two different
SaaS solution offering.
One is a SaaS e-commerce solution
providing a tenant-specific
product management
in terms of product catalog
where tenants can configure
their product catalog.
Similarly, tenants can also
configure their order management
in terms of order processing workflow
based on the product that
they have configured.
And these tenants can also interact
with the second solution offering
about the SaaS retrieval
augmented generation,
where tenants can onboard their
organizational related data
and that data would be indexed,
you know, in a vectored store.
And then the vector, based on
the tenant specific context
along with the user
query from the tenants,
would be passed to generative AI LLMs
to generate the response.
And accordingly, the
response is sent back.
In terms of both of these solutions,
tenant isolation, noisy neighbor,
in terms of the SaaS fundamentals
that we talked about,
are super critical to ensure
that you maintain those boundaries.
And we will see in practical
sense on some of the patterns
that how do you verify the
tenant isolation working
as expected based on your
authorization strategy
that you would've implemented
as part of your SaaS architecture.
Now what we have seen earlier
is just a kind of a workflow
or a very logical construct of
how tenants interact, right?
So beyond SaaS provider and tenants,
you could have multiple
other personas as well,
depending on your nature of
business and the interactions.
So what you see here is an AWS
SaaS reference architecture
for today's setup.
So we have the topmost
layer of user access layer
where tenants are interacting
with the SaaS application
and, again, they are also interacting
with the RAG application
based on the integration
with Cognito for authentication
and authorization.
And the user access
the SaaS provider specific
control plane related components.
You remember I talked about
the control plane components
in the previous slides.
So all of these
functionalities are managed
by the SaaS provider in
terms of the control plane.
And the control plane talks
to the application plane
through an Amazon EventBridge
as an event driven pattern.
And the first interface
of the control plane
is a core application plane
offered through a kind of,
or tenant workflow authorization
in terms of managing the
tenant onboarding process
as well as the other integration elements.
We also have an EKS application
plane hosted as a pool model
offering the tenant specific
name spaces in terms of order
and the product related microservices
having their respective data stored
in terms of the DynamoDB.
And we also have a siloed deployment model
of a serverless application plane
as a serverless architecture,
where tenants are specific
on their deployment model
where they can adopt the
serverless architecture as well
in terms of the order processing workflow.
And then we have a
generative AI application
providing the retrieval
augmented generation
with a shared service model of
where tenants are sharing
the same infrastructure
in spite of isolating the
tenants in terms of their data,
in terms of their
interaction, authorization,
and all other SaaS fundamentals
that we talked about.
Now let's talk about resilience
testing patterns, right?
So I've been talking
about resilience testing
all the time, right?
So resilience testing is about
how do you induce purposeful
faults into your workload
to validate your assumptions
with the controlled bounded context
to ensure that doesn't impact
your critical workloads
or end customer experience.
So this is more around how do
you define those hypothesis
and induce the fault
and improve the overall
resiliency posture.
Now before we get into the patterns,
I just want to quickly talk about
the multi-account structure
and the setup that we have
done for today's patterns
where you can see we
have picked two regions,
US East 1 and US West 2,
and there are multiple personas
interact with this solution.
So we have a phase administrator
who could be an SRE admin
or lead or DevOps SRE or elite,
who's trying to actually
perform this fault.
And then tenants interacting
with the solution
and then we have SaaS provider.
So we have AWS organization as a route
under which we have a test OU.
And these test OU have
four different accounts
performing specific role in the
overall multi-account setup.
So where we have account one representing
the single pane of glass
for AWS FIS experiments
with the AWS FIS experiment orchestration.
And then we have account two
representing the control plane
and the e-commerce application plane,
where we have system manager
to induce custom faults
based on the system manager
documents along with AWS STS
to perform cross account authorization
with the FIS experiment target.
And then we have again account
three for the RAG solution
and then we have account four
where we want to actually
observe various system behaviors
using Amazon CloudWatch
with the cross account observability.
We also have some bucket
policies configured
for one of the patterns
to replicate the data
from your primary region
to the secondary region.
So this is how you would
set up for your workload
in terms of multi-account architecture
for your fault injection service.
So again, if you see that account two
and account three is an
example for today's stock,
but you could have 10 or
20 or hundreds of accounts
depending on the complexity
of your business,
where your workloads are running,
you want to induce the faults,
still account one and
account four could be
your single pane of glass
from your FIS orchestration perspective
and observability perspective.
And account two and
account three can replicate
across multiple accounts.
So you need to carefully design
how your odd structure is,
how the account structure is,
how you want to create the hypothesis
to ensure that you see the
real value out of this.
So let's get started with pattern one.
So pattern one is a
multi-tenant noisy neighbor.
So how many of you have experienced
multi-tenant noisy neighbor
scenario for your workloads?
Cool.
So it's a scenario where
one tenant's activity
adversely affecting the
overall service performance
or other tenants.
And to mitigate this, SaaS
provider typically adopt
a workload management and
resource allocation strategy.
And one of the common method
is to have a throttling mechanism
to ensure that tenants are accessing
or stays within their quota
limits configured per tenant.
Now what you see is an AWS
reference architecture where,
you know, as I mentioned earlier,
in terms of the resilience testing phases,
we start with the steady state
in terms of Amazon CloudWatch
to observe how the system is behaving
and then we move on to
defining an hypothesis,
and then we go ahead
and run the experiment.
We come back and verify
and then we improve in
terms of our learnings.
So in terms of the tenant interaction,
so where we have two
tenants for pattern one,
tenant one is a security
ISV, deals with threat data,
and we have tenant who's an HR tech ISV,
deals with the employee award data.
And both of these tenants
performing their respective
RAG query against API gateway,
and the API gateway has been
configured with the usage plan
to limit per tenant request
in terms of 10,000 tokens
and 500 input tokens
and 500 output tokens
with 100 requests per day.
And the API gateway is attached
with the Lambda authorizer,
which actually extracts the JWT token,
understands the tenant
specific token limits
and also validates the role
along with the dynamically
generates the tenant scope,
the credentials,
which are passed towards Lambda
RAG service and it also...
Sorry, the Lambda authorizer also checks
against the DynamoDB
to ensure that the tenant
stays within the limit.
And once the response is received
from the Lambda authorizer,
then the API gateway forwards the request
towards Lambda RAG service,
and its job is to invoke
Amazon Bedrock knowledge base
to specifically retrieve
the tenant context
from Amazon OpenSearch vector store,
which are already vectorized
based on the data ingestion workflow,
which is not shown here,
but the context is retrieved
along with the user query.
Both of those information is
passed to Amazon Bedrock LLM
to generate the response,
and accordingly, the
response is sent back.
So this covers the overall flow of,
you know, the retrieval
augmented generation.
And on the top you see
is an Amazon EventBridge,
where every one minute,
the EventBridge rule
invokes the Amazon Lambda
in terms of the token usage,
and then its only job is to
analyze the CloudWatch logs
and then it updates the DynamoDB table,
which'll be used by the Lambda authorizer.
Now what we want to do in
terms of the hypothesis
is to induce two kind of faults.
One is to actually disable
the EventBridge rule
and second fault is to actually delete the
CloudWatch log streams.
And after inducing this fault,
we want to validate what will
happen to our system behavior
in terms of whether tenants
can actually bypass those
throttling limits or they
stay within the limits
to simulate or understand
the noisy neighbor scenario.
So let's quickly jump
onto the AWS console.
So hope you are able to see my screen.
So what you see on the
screen is the four accounts
that we have set up,
where as an administrator I can
further into these accounts.
Now in terms of the code setup...
Let be quickly connect.
So in terms of the code setup,
so you can see that we have a tenant,
so this is a project for the RAG.
We have a CDK under which
we have tenant template.
Tenant template has
multiple code repositories
in terms of the Python modules.
So you can see the Bedrock custom services
have individual modules
related to the Python.
And then we also have
multiple other TypeScript CDK,
which actually performs various activities
in terms of creating roles,
deploying the AWS resources,
and trying to bundle the
overall Python modules
into Lambda and deploy that.
And the correlation of
these Python modules,
you can see for example
we have Bedrock custom,
we have a Python module
which is associated
with a specific TypeScript CDK,
where you can see that
the TypeScript is invoking
or referenced towards the
Bedrock custom Python module
with the specific Bedrock
log Python with the handler
and the handler with the
specific Lambda functions.
And you can also see that
based on the TypeScript CDK,
it generates the log group
along with the role ARN,
which is passed as an
environmental variable
towards the TypeScript
where the CDK creates the
cloud formation script,
it deploys the necessary resources,
and it also uploads or packages
the overall Python code
into Lambda function
and it uploads into S3,
and the cloud formation
actually deploys as a Lambda.
So this is just one example
for the Bedrock related functionality
in terms of the tenant token usage.
Similarly, we have the services
under which you can see the RAG service.
We have the core RAG service
in terms of the Lambda,
which has the similar
functionality of showcasing,
you know, like, let me go back
to the respective TypeScript here.
So we have service.ts
which is again a TypeScript
specific to the RAG service.
And you can see here
we have also referenced
the authorizer Lambda along with
the specific combined
attribute based access control,
which we are using for the
authorization strategy.
And you can see that we have
the authorization service
referenced again with the
specific Python module
with the Lambda handler
in terms of the function
and the necessary enrollment
variables are passed,
which are again correlated
with your TypeScript
along with your Python module packages.
So the way the project is set up,
where we are using
infrastructure as a code
along with the Python
to bundle it, deploy it,
to ensure that any changes that we do
as part of the SaaS workload
architecture are deployed
in a simplified way and easy to maintain
and we can mitigate any sort of failures.
Now what I've done is...
So I have two terminals here,
terminal one and terminal two.
Just to save some time, I've
already executed a script here.
So just to show you the
tenant related information.
So let me just go back and execute.
So here, like as I mentioned earlier,
we have two tenants configured,
tenant one and tenant two.
So tenant one have their
respective registration ID
along with the email address
with the tenant config,
reference to input token,
output token, API gateway.
Similarly, we have tenant two
with their specific
registration ID, email address,
and then the tenant specific
configuration as well.
Now to understand the
steady state behavior
for this pattern one,
I've actually executed a
script with a invoke API
towards the API gateway
with the specific input, the tenant name.
And I'm trying to ask a question here,
what are the threats related
to gather host information?
I'm sending 13 requests.
And as you can see,
each of the requests I'm
receiving HTTP status code.
200, sounds great. Until
request number seven.
And then from request eight onwards
I have received HTTP status code 403,
which is access denied.
And this is because tenant
one has already overshooted
in terms of their token limits,
considering the noisy neighbor scenario.
And then we have tenant
two, who are actually,
I'm performing the same query,
but in this case the query is different
because the tenant context is different.
So who are the employees
received award for the teamwork?
And I'm sending four requests
just to differentiate.
And all of the requests are succeeded.
Now this validates that, okay,
now we have the throttling
strategy in place.
And now with this,
we want to just quickly
jump onto the AWS console
where I've configured a
dashboard for pattern one
where we have various
observability metrics
related to the AWS
services to understand how
tenants are using our services.
So we have a DynamoDB
latency and throttling,
we have DynamoDB token
usage, table operation,
Bedrock invocation metrics and all that.
And we also have the respective
authorization in terms of,
you know, the Lambda attached
to the API gateway to analyze,
and I can just show you one of the error
why you have received 403.
And the reason is because
tenant token limit exceeded.
Now I want to go ahead
and induce the fault
that I talked about.
So what you see is an AWS console
where you have FIS service
aligned with the resilience testing,
and then we have resilience management
related to Resilience Hub.
So as I mentioned earlier,
the first thing is you'll
configure the experiment templates
where I already configured here,
and you also have scenario libraries
based on the various
experiments that you run
in terms of the overall status,
and you have spotlights to talk about
the various blocks and all that.
So once you understand the steady state,
you come to this experiment
template where I've configured
"noisy neighbor fault,
disable EventBridge rule."
So let me click there and
then start the experiment.
So I've started the experiment.
Now what we are expecting
to do is FIS would induce
those both of the faults
into our multi-tenant account.
And you can see that we
have this experiment ID
along with the account
targeting is a multi-account,
and we have IAM role configured,
currently it's in the running state
and you can export the
experiment into reports as well.
And we have two actions
based on what I explained
as the architectural reference.
So one is to disrupt the EventBridge rule
using AWS SSM send-command,
which is a custom fault.
And again, some of the AWS
services have native integration
of FIS, where FIS can induce
the faults into AWS services.
But in this case, because
it's a SaaS workload,
I have the flexibility to
configure my own custom fault.
So that is why I'm using AWS
SSM send manager send-command,
which eventually uses
system manager documents.
So document is a custom
set of steps or scripts
that you want to induce in your
SaaS workload architectures.
So both of these actions have completed.
Similarly, have another
action or activity using,
again, AWS systems send-command
where I want to delete the
CloudWatch log streams.
And then you have the targets.
So in this case, since you're
using an SSM system manager,
you would eventually use an EC2 instance,
which will use SSM agent
to perform those actions.
And then we have a target account
where we have deployed the RAG solution,
we have tags, timeline, and log events.
Now this experiment is completed.
Now with this, I want to
ensure that, you know,
in terms of the observability,
let me go back and show
you the alarm here.
So let me refresh.
So I have an alarm created
as I induce the fault.
And you can see this has deleted
one of the log stream action,
which ensure that we have fault induced.
Now can anyone guess that
whether if I send the
same request query again,
would that succeed?
Because already tenant one
has overshoot on their limits.
Any idea?
(person speaking indistinctly)
Yeah, the faults have been induced.
- [Attendee] So then there's
nothing reverting it.
(speaks indistinctly)
- [Kanniah] Exactly.
So it's going to fail because
the Lambda authorizer,
the Lambda that was attached
to the EventBridge rule
has already captured by
analyzing the CloudWatch log
and it updated the DynamoDB.
Now any request going
in the Lambda authorizer
would actually go back
and check in the DynamoDB
and it says that, okay,
now this tenant has already
overshooted on the limits
in spite of inducing the fault, right?
So for today's demo,
I'm going to reset the DynamoDB table
so that at least we'll see
what'll be the behavior
based on the faults that we have induced.
So what you see on the
screen is an DynamoDB table
related to the token usage.
So I'm just going to go
ahead and reset this,
but in real world production system,
you won't be able to do this
and you don't need to do it, right,
because this is an example of,
the throttling limit is already being set
and we have a tracking
mechanism using DynamoDB table,
because of which you
won't be able to do it.
So now I've reset the DynamoDB table.
Now I go back and fire the
same set of experiments
to see what happens.
So I go back to the Visual Studio Code
and I send the same request now.
So here we are validating our,
we actually have executed the hypothesis,
we run the experiment and
now we are trying to verify.
So I'm going to send
the same request here,
13 request for tenant one.
And then similarly, I'm going to send,
this time I'm going to send 14 requests
or 13 requests for tenant two,
just to see how both of
these tenants perform
in terms of the throttling limits.
So this is going to take
some time to complete,
probably couple of minutes.
Let me see if this request is proceeding
to ensure that after we
reset the DynamoDB table...
Yes, so we are receiving the response,
so let it go through.
So meanwhile, let me quickly jump on to
the experiment templates to showcase you
how this looks in real world.
So again, what I've showed you
is an AWS console version of
visualizing how the
experiment has behaved.
You can also configure a
JSON and upload that into,
you can actually import it into FIS
and then experiment can be configured.
So here I'm just going to quickly show you
the experiment template, how it looks.
It's a similar version of the UI,
but here it's pretty much clear that
first you have to configure the action.
In this case, we have
two actions configured
with the action ID of
SSM send-command with,
you can see that the document ARN.
So this is super critical
if you want to induce a custom fault.
And this is a system manager
document with the document ARN
and the duration is one minute
and the target is our instance,
because it's a send-command.
So whereas if you induce a Lambda fault
or maybe EKS Pod actions,
then you would see that the action ID
would be respective AWS services.
So we have two actions configured
and you can see that the
second action has again
a different ARN,
and then we have the description,
you can export into report,
you can also do a log configuration,
and the targets are configured
with their respective EC2 instances.
You can see that both of these
resource ARN are associated
with an EC2 instance in the same account.
And now if you go back
and show you the SSM documents as well,
so this is how the SSM
documents looks, right?
So you have a schema
version with the parameters
passed as an input in terms
of the log stream delete.
So you are passing which
log stream to be deleted
with the run command, with the log group,
and set of, you know, steps
against the AWS services.
Similarly, you have for the
EventBridge rule as well.
So this is how you will
configure an experiment
tied with the specific action commands
using the system manager.
So we are just waiting for
this script to complete.
So meanwhile let me jump on to, sorry.
So let's quickly jump on to pattern two.
So pattern two about
tenant isolation, right?
So one of the critical principle
of any multi-tenant solution,
how do you ensure that your tenants
are not able to access other tenants' data
or the resources, right?
So what kinda strategy you would use?
Any volunteers?
What is a common method of
tenant isolation strategy?
Sorry?
- [Attendee 2] Different accounts.
- [Kanniah] Different accounts,
that could be one strategy,
but still how do you control, you know,
your principles are not able to bypass
accessing other tenants'
resources or even the data
in terms of data isolation?
(person speaking indistinctly)
Yeah, that's one strategy.
- [Attendee 3] STP.
- [Kanniah] Sorry?
- [Kanniah] Yeah, that's more
of the info certain policies
that you want to bring in
as part of your multi-account strategy.
So to have a robust tenant
isolation mechanism,
customers typically adopt
three authorization strategies.
Number one is role-based access control,
where every tenant will
have their specified role
and that role will say that
which specific AWS resources
that they can use.
For example, you know, you
have an EC2 with S3 and RDS.
So you can have a role defined per tenant
and based on that
particular authorization,
you can restrict those
specific AWS resources.
The second mechanism is
to dynamically generate
an IAM policy for each tenant
based on IAM identities.
It could be IAM user or role.
The third common strategy
is to use IAM role
with attribute based access control,
where you define an attribute
based access control policy
and attach that to a tag
and that tag will decide
which specific IAM principle
in terms of the role can
access which resource.
Now for the RAG solution, we
have adopted the third strategy
of using IAM role with
attribute based access control.
So what you see is very
similar to pattern one.
The only difference or the point
that I want to highlight is
whenever a tenant sends their query,
Lambda authorizer dynamically, you know,
dynamically generates an attribute based
access control policy,
or tenant scoped credentials,
as part of the request,
and then it passes that to the API gateway
and the API gateway
passes those credentials
based on the principle
in terms of the IAM role
attached with that tag.
And that tag will be eventually
passed on to the Lambda
that is RAG service to
ensure that when it invokes,
for example, the knowledge
base or any other resources,
it will try to match that tag.
If both of those principle tag
and the resource tag matches,
then the request would be authorized.
If not, they would get access
denied (indistinct), right?
So this is the common strategy
using attribute based access control.
Now in terms of the hypothesis,
what we want to do is we want
to induce a microservice bug.
This could be a human error or any other,
you know, coding level issues could happen
that someone mistakenly
hardcoded the knowledge base ID
of tenant two into tenant one, right?
Which may not happen but
anything could happen
in terms of the failures.
So if that's the case,
whether tenant one can bypass
and access the tenant two data
is what something that we will validate.
And let me quickly go back and see.
So what you all see on the
screen for the pattern one,
you can see that compared
to the previous iteration,
now all of those tenant
requests have succeeded.
So as we induce the fault,
so tenant one can completely
execute 13 requests
and tenant two can also
proceed to execute 13 request.
So based on the fault that we've induced
and after we reset the DynamoDB table,
tenants can actually
overshoot on their limits,
which is a sort of a violation
from a throttling mechanism
standpoint, right?
So it means tenants can actually
create more number of volume of requests,
which could actually jeopardize
the overall SaaS solution
in terms of the account level
or regional level limits.
So some of the key
learnings for pattern one
is that how do you enforce an
IAM least privileged mechanism
to restrict any of your IAM identities
within your organization or accounts
cannot go ahead and delete such,
you know, IAM rules or logs or anything
that would actually restrict
your tenant behavior.
The second strategies,
if such fault happens,
how do you ensure that overall,
the legitimate tenants who
are still within the limits,
because of the noisy
neighbor of multiple tenant
trying to create more number of requests
would actually put other tenants
to receive a throttling error
because of your account level
or regional level quotas
that you have already pre-provisioned.
So how do you mitigate that?
So this is where you have to
look at the broader scope of
the tenant and the noisy neighbor scenario
of mitigating the throttling mechanism.
And last but not the least is
to have a more notification
and alerting strategy
for the SaaS provider
to know if there are certain tenants
who are actually bypassing
those throttling limits
and accordingly have some sort
of automation or remediation
to actually go back and
increase those quota limits
either at the account
level or regional level.
Now, in terms of the other patterns,
so have pattern three for
serverless applications.
How many of you have
adopted serverless patterns
for your workloads?
Okay.
So, again, serverless is one of the,
you know, modern architecture
that most of the customers
try to adopt because of,
you know, reliability and high
availability as we manage,
you know, in terms of
infrastructure and you try to focus
on your specific application
related components.
Now one of the common challenge
with the serverless
application is timeouts, right?
Because you have so many
serverless architectural components
where you would have a circular dependency
between components and maybe upstream
or downstream systems as well.
So to work on this challenge,
how do you induce a purposeful fault
within your serverless architecture
to identify those system dependencies
or the timeout scenarios?
So one of the common pattern is
where you could actually
induce AWS Lambda faults,
again using FIS,
which is a native
capability that we support,
where you can induce the Lambda faults
in terms of adding a
latency into your Lambda
and identify how this user behavior
and the various other system components,
like API gateway, error rates increasing,
or maybe the user error rates increasing
where user have a bad experience.
Now, again, you can
leverage FIS to do this
and the common pattern is again know,
you will adopt or go
through the same phases
of implementing it.
And the fourth pattern
is the EKS application
high availability.
Managing workloads within
EKS is complex task, right?
Because of so many, you know,
dependencies within the EKS
of configuring Pods, node clusters,
and various other, you know,
internal dependencies of your Kubernetes.
So one of the common patterns
where customer adopt FIS
is to actually induce EKS Pod actions.
And we have so many Pod actions
that we support natively
in terms of terminating your instances,
in terms of the node group servers,
and also inducing the CPU stress.
I will stress memory and latencies.
So all of those faults are
natively supported as part of FIS
where you can induce the
CPU stress, for example,
you know, against multiple tenants,
where tenants could be isolated
based on the namespaces.
And in this case, the tenants
are trying to create a request
towards tenant one and tenant two.
And both of those tenants
where you can actually label the faults
based on the application selector,
based on the application
selector as your criteria,
you can induce the fault.
And some of the dependencies
or prerequisites
for you to induce the faults,
you have to configure
Kubernetes service accounts.
The Kubernetes service account
is a role-based mechanism
where you provide certain
permissions to FIS
to actually create an FIS Pod,
which will sit along
with your existing Pods
in your clusters to induce those faults
to ensure that the EKS failures
in terms of the Pod
actions can be mitigated.
Now I have another pattern
about cross-region data replication
on how to use S3 post replication,
you know, if you're dealing with
multi-regional architectures,
where especially the data
(indistinct) workflow
have a complex steps,
and if you're relying upon S3
to replicate the data using cross-region,
then this could be one of the
pattern that you can adopt
to induce faults across
multiple regions as well.
If anyone is interested,
please let me know.
I'm happy to discuss.
Now in terms of the key takeaways,
the first and fundamental element
is to understand your
workload architecture, right?
So what are the system dependencies
that you want to validate
and are you interested to
identify cross regional failures
or you're trying to validate how
one of the component would fail
will have circular dependency
on other components.
So understanding your
end-to-end workload architecture
is super critical for resilience testing.
And then once you understand
your architecture,
proceed towards identifying
the key objective
of resilience testing.
So again, you know, if you don't know
what specific hypothesis
that you want to create
in terms of resilience testing,
it is going to be very difficult
for you to justify what
was the business outcome
and how do you justify the outcomes
aligned with the improvement
of your workload architecture.
And that is where you
define your hypothesis
with a real consideration
of the weaknesses
and what validation that you want to do.
And then accordingly run the experiments.
This is where you can use FIS experiments
based on the various
supports that we offered.
And then finally, once
you run the experiment,
once you verify the real benefit would be
based on the outcomes.
The outcomes is the learning
that you have identified
and then accordingly improvise
your resiliency posture
to ensure that you can
withstand those failures
or disruptions based on your testing.
And then as you mature throughout your
resilience testing phases,
ensure that you would be able to
integrate resilience
testing as part of your CICD
as a continuous iterative process.
And again, you know, resilience testing
is a continuous iterative process,
just not one time activity,
because your system would
evolve, team would change,
and you would have various
disruptions to handle.
So ensure that you perform
the resilience testing
in a continuous iterative process.
Feel free to grab this QR code
if you're really interested
to deep dive on various
other best practices
and guidance from AWS.
And again, if you're interested
to have one-to-one demos
or even opportunity to
grab some of the swags,
meet us at the kiosk in the AWS Village.
And last but not the least,
if you really want to
upskill your AWS knowledge,
feel free to register
on AWS Skill Builder,
where you have thousands
of on-demand trainings
as well as hands-on experience as well.